good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday today we're going to talk about
superstitious generals Mormons
long-distance swimming and the Nobel
Peace Prize can you guess the country to
which I'm referring Kenya Kenya I'll
give you the entire intro to come up
with your answer that's right Hank Burma
okay hey first a quick background of
Burmese history including a
justification of why I'm saying Burma
and not Myanmar Burma is a nation in
Southeast Asia bordering Thailand China
and India Burma was a British colony
then it gained its independence in 1948
and then from 1948 to 1962 it had a kind
of British styled democracy and it was
the wealthiest nation in Southeast Asia
and then in 1962 there was a military
coup in Burma got overtaken by crazy
people Hank have you ever noticed that
what happens after the words there was a
military coup is generally pretty bad I
wonder if there's any way we could get a
memo out to you know like military's
explaining to them that cooing is bad
so now after 47 years of military rule
Burma is one of the poorest and most
oppressive places in the world okay so
in 1989 the crazy military rulers of
Burma decided that they were going to
rename the country Myanmar and now lots
of people refer to it as Myanmar but I
don't because there were a military coup
in the United States of America and our
new military rulers announced that the
new name of our country was going to be
the Democratic Socialist Republic of
poopyface funny pants I wouldn't want
people to call my homeland poopy face
bunny pants so anyway that's why I call
it Burma
so the original crazy Burmese general
was a guy named nee Winn who bathed in
the blood of dolphins because he thought
it would keep him young and who famously
tried to change the Burmese currency
from base-10 like all other currencies
in the world to base 9 because 9 was his
lucky number so for a while all the
currency in Burma was issued in
multiples of 9 when it finally came time
for nay win to resign he decided to do
it on the astrologically auspicious date
of 8 888 immediately after nee win
resigned in 1988 there were these huge
student protests to which the Burmese
government responded by killing more
than 10,000 protesters one of the
leaders of those protests was a maid of
awesome woman named Allison su Chi and
in 1991
Terry government of Burma finally bound
to international pressure and agreed to
have elections
Allinson su Chi won and everyone is like
this is great we're gonna this awesome
lady Azhar prime minister but the
military is like no no no no no we said
that we would have elections we didn't
say that we would honor the results of
those elections so make the next year
round since uchi won the Nobel Peace
Prize and I'm sure you know what the
Burmese government gives you if you win
the Nobel Peace Prize house arrest in
fact Hank Allen's and Suchi has been
stuck inside of her lakefront house for
most of the last 20 years bouncing sushi
is seen by the Burmese people in much
the same way that Gandhi is seen by the
Indian people she's so popular that the
Burmese generals are scared of killing
her but Hank a condition of her house
arrested that she's not allowed to have
foreign visitors enter mentally
disturbed mormon evangelists american
john yet al okay so earlier this year an
American named John yet al abandoned his
family and flew to Burma he then swims
across the large lake outside of
Allanson su cheese house and shows up at
her doorstep apparently he was almost
dead from the swim so Anson su Chi being
the compassionate person she is let him
stay for a couple of days and recover
then he got caught and he was trying to
sneak back out and now Anson su Chi has
been arrested in faces five years in
prison for violating the terms of her
house arrest so you can arrest it and
you go to prison because somebody swam
to your house how can the government get
away with that Hank one of the answers
is that Burma's neighbors refused to
tell them hey Burma stop being so crazy
now obviously it's hard to get a country
like China fired up about human rights
but Burma's other neighbors specifically
India need to put much more pressure on
the Burmese government to really reform
otherwise Burma will never have the
opportunity to be led by its Ghandi Hank
you'll see me on Tuesday when
nerdfighters I will be answering your
questions please leave them in comments
by the way Australian nerdfighters if
you want to see me in Sydney on June 3rd
there's information in the sidebar about
how to book your spot